penny la subaru depuis juin 2011 les
brigades rapides d'intervention de la
gendarmerie sont équipées de renault
mégane un véhicule qui peut afficher 260
km/heure au compteur de quoi pouvoir
prendre en chasse des véhicules rapides
tels que dans les situations de go fast
ces trafiquants qui font transiter la
drogue dans leurs coffres de voitures
via les circuits autoroutier mais nous
sommes un département porteur puisque
nous sommes sur l'axé principal qui
relie
l'espagne le maroc à la région
parisienne ou à la belgique donc c'est
un phénomène qui a une reconnaissance
sur le territoire national et nous
sommes donc forcément touchés par ce
phénomène mais cela reste bien minime
dans l'émission menée par les trois
agents de la br i dans le département
les 270 chevaux sous le capot servent
principalement à l'arrestation le
délinquant routier en moyenne c'est un
retrait de permis par jour avec parfois
des complications et maintenant avec le
système du permis à points énormément de
personnes ont peur pour leur devenir en
cas de rétention de permis de conduire à
ne serait-ce que pour coire seront de
travail ou assurer leurs activités de
tous les jours nous sommes confrontés
principalement à une recrudescence en
recrutant perret ou des personnes ne
veulent plus s'arrêter un peu de
contrôle
les gendarmes habilité à conduire le
véhicule ont tous suivi une formation
initiale d'une semaine sur circuit à
brest et sont testés tous les deux ans
le véhicule quand à lui est remplacé
tous les cinq ans